if I walk into this kitchen and I see a
cantaloupe on that table all right now
bill dance dance get up and dance like
Dirty Dancing
get up like Dirty Dancing right now and
I'm like what it's not a strip saw my
dirty dancing it goes yes be like dirty
dancing remember like dirty dancing
Patrick Swayze be like Patrick Swayze
Jennifer gray up in the air
we all were like we all lost it yeah
Swayze you idiot
Harry Styles for the personal trainer
[Laughter]
now you could put more on than that go
ahead you could put more on than no dude
try it
no take it off take it off see let me
start by saying I have nothing against
guns and I'm not just saying that
because I look like a bullet I mean if
this guy can walk out of a gun store
without answering some questions
something has gone wrong
I mean they make me answer five
questions at the deli I went to Kansas
City with Alec and Marcy to try to get
vtk killer off death row
[Applause]
they said here comes BTK I go you know
his name is Dennis
human beat and wanted a yeah IV like I
was at Natanz II with Mick and jeffrey
dahmer
[Laughter]
we had this young man was our waiter and
he left and and Jeffrey said I have to
go to the bathroom I see of course you
do I like to buy a dozen donuts with
this gift certificate and I'd also like
your biggest bottle of yoohoo I'm sorry
I see how much of the donuts without the
gift certificate
I see 1978 I was living with Paul Simon
and Ted Bundy cause we were with the
serial killer yeah how dark is crowded I
know this is a really crap
[Applause]
[Applause]
the mosquito is half filled with blood
and flexes it
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah hey what are you looking at but it
why don't you make like a tree and get
out of here you know that that is a
great line it is so great the stuff you
guys are doing with the 50s and
everything I know I had jackets like
this annually Laemmle on the old guy I
heard you two nutless liberal a sweet
Bayes mention my name earlier and when I
hear my name three times
I appear like a Goomba Beetlejuice Puff
the Magic Dragon huffed and puffed and
then kept puffing and puffed some more
and then he like got some Oreos with his
friends that puffs aboard then like he
watched Jerry Springer for like five
days
I'm four and a half father this is the
bombing do I need to pull up on now baby
so much fun I want to watch doc
McStuffins hello I'm Bob Simon sometimes
here 60 minutes you pull the short straw
there for two years wheel does not to
roll your way I heard about my new
assignment I thought where am I going
the White House that couple over have no
I was then 8,000 miles away to hellhole
Africa to cover Jaguar poacher Murphy
has this real kind of singsong way but
he always gets things he's like an old
kind of news reporter he always gets
stories about like young kids like
murdering each other so be like you know
Katie and Cara were BFFs I just bought
the new future raw album that has just
dropped and they were smoking cush and
twerking like just trying to fit in
there lol's quickly turned to WTF
fred talks his hands and he just talks
about portland all the time I love
Portland I fly over there I have my
apartment you're gonna order a lemonade
for me little child and if you don't
order a lemonade for me you're right to
hell yo he says you could have a
drinking game with this every time he'll
kill this it goes so your father dead
now most people when I find a dead body
in their house they call 9-1-1 John
Travolta in that he always uses his
hands his hands are just so it's like
they're only made to handle teacups like
a little teapot I went down to Venice
Beach we're in the 60s a band taught us
that if we work hard we can't break on
through to the other side oh please
don't no please don't do that
oh oh oh oh please I can't jump that
high in the air but like a boat one hand
like this I can do that it's not if you
can see me but Kendrick tell me what
happened
what can I say I like to kill kill like
a comedian at the Apollo so I waited for
Elroy and when I saw him I took a
machete oh you gotta
and I hacked him to death and I'm the
one who did it yeah yeah I think I did a
dying conte on you want me to do it
again yeah Sawyer you saw your father
shot in the face
I must been a while so I don't care for
bomber runs the ball or Romney throws a
touchdown or Ron Paul kicks a field goal
that's tiny little chicken legs I'll
tell you right now though I put in
Santorum in the game he can stand on the
sidelines do it cheers in his little
sweater vests
[ __ ] oh honey job interview I can play
the guitar and that's about it
[Applause]